we're also trying to give you as many
newsmakers as possible and this man is
exactly that right in the middle of
everything for the philadelphia eagles
the executive vice president general
manager of the philadelphia eagles howie
roseman back here on the show
how are you howie rich i gotta tell you
you guys have drew mcintyre on next i
got two little boys
two of my four kids who are going to be
so excited
to hear about drew mcintyre they are
every day
wwe watching listening i mean this is
unbelievable i'm fired up
for that after i'm well are they in the
car right now howie
are they it sounds like you're driving
in the car right now are they in the car
right now with you
they are they are not in the car they're
at school we're back in school in
philadelphia which is a beautiful thing
okay because i would have introduced you
as nfl superstar howie roseman if they
were in the car
just you know that's awesome you you
know you know
you know you got kids you know it's all
about them
it's about daddy points too let's be
honest come on anytime you could play
everything
exactly all right boy have you been in
the middle of
everything man i mean uh let me just
let's walk through if you don't mind um
the first time you got a phone call
from the dolphins and did they tell you
that this was contingent upon something
they were working with the niners and
you had to keep all of that quiet way
back in march
like there was just like an nba
three-team deal that was going on is
that really what this was
i know it was exciting you know i i
think we tried to talk about it
theoretically hey theoretically would
you guys move back if we move back and
want to move back up
and and then it gets to a point where
you're going all right all right dude
like
you're gonna have to trust me here
because i'm gonna have to figure out
where you're going so i can figure out
if we want to do it right
and i think that's the great thing about
about the relationships we have with
those two teams is
everyone trusted one another and it
really didn't get out
until zach wilson threw
[Laughter]
that's pretty much it because you know
so yeah cause you're like why would you
move out of
six to go down to 12 if if you didn't
know
who who was coming up to three and for
what and for who
you know you had to know we had to get
all the information because we had to
figure out all right here are the
players that we want to come i mean we
had a miserable year right rich like
that wasn't fun
and certainly our country had a
miserable year more importantly
but we wanted to come out of this draft
and get a difference maybe get someone
who really
would have huge impact on our football
team and
we had to make sure that we were going
to do that and for us
and where we sit right now um it's crazy
to think you know three years ago
on the show talking about us being world
champs but uh we knew that
for us to get a difference maker and end
up with an
additional first round pick in the 2022
draft where maybe things were a little
bit more certain
made sense for for our football team and
our franchise well i mean
you know obviously eagles fans were
lockstep with you and wanting to get a
big time playmaker or somebody who could
make a difference and
when you traded out a six i think you're
aware and you're in your neck of the
woods people kind of
flipping or freaked that you were giving
up a chance of pits and chase and
is there any sort of um i guess solace
that you
take in the fact that subsequently
now in 2020 hindsight neither would have
been there at six anyway
for you well i think that that we had to
make that part of the discussion when we
were moving back like what do we really
think is gonna happen
obviously you know we're not in the
atlanta falcons or cincinnati bengals
facility so
we don't know for sure but when we went
through we thought there was a strong
possibility that that may occur
uh and for us being able to get this
pick and the certainty of the pick and
knowing how hard those are to get during
the draft
and knowing that we felt like there were
a bunch of really
good outcomes for us with that first
round pick
we made the decision but i can't tell
you there are moments that
um we're putting a lot of a lot of
religions prayers together
i i normally ask questions that i kind
of know the answer to first so
i'm rolling the dice here have you ever
made a trade with the dallas cowboys
before
that your first last year actually uh we
we moved
we moved back in uh from the end of the
fourth round to the top of the fifth and
got it next year fifth and then
um we made one with coach reed uh when
we traded back in the first round
and they took anthony spencer and we
moved back to the second round and took
kevin cobb
so this has happened before this wasn't
truly you know man bites dog in a way
but was that something that you already
had planned
and that you you pushed the button uh on
and called up the cowboys uh once
devonte smith was you knew
available at 10 or how does something
like that work
howie you know it's funny because in the
week up to the draft you know
um our rpr guys that are
we do an unbelievable job bob lang fred
show shocker
they're unbelievable um they're telling
me everyone thinks you know you're
making all these calls to moving up and
i'm going
yeah definitely making a tough ton of
costs
we're making a tough call to the teams
in front of us and the team's behind us
and
that's our job right like we got to
figure out what the opportunities are
going to be so
you know you're making all those calls
before the draft to figure out
who's willing who's open so you're not
starting from scratch on the clock when
you know uh all hell's breaking loose
i'm not sure if i'm allowed to say that
yes you are absolutely that works and so
that's then that's how
but you don't you don't exact the trade
until you know
that you get the call from you know nfl
hq
to find out that the broncos did not
take the guy that you were willing to
trade up to
two spots to go get right that's how
that works right i mean
right then you will you kind of wait for
it we get to pick about a minute before
um it's announced and then you kind of
spring into action
and i think the one thing we were
certain of was that
it wasn't going to be the lightest draft
capital
going from two slots in the history of
the draft so we knew that wasn't gonna
happen well it's interesting
we knew what we knew it wasn't gonna
happen for like you know a sixth and a
and a and uh
and a pile of cheese dates right but
it's interesting to use the word
lightest when you were referring to who
you eventually took
and the concept about devonta smith
being 166 pounds soaking wet the comp
that actually came out of my brain
believe it or not
since i'm not usually in the business of
player comps that we put up on the
screen on nfl network was alan iverson
um saw that and the mock draft my sons
you know they showed me that and um
uh i think i think that devonte is
unique player unique player unique
person and
now sometimes you get to this level and
everyone's trying to go well
look for the perfect comp but sometimes
the guys that
that are really special players don't
necessarily have
that perfect comp and that could be hard
for us sometimes
you know when we talk about making
selections and comparing players but
um i i think that's really important uh
as we go forward to just look at what he
does and who he is
and so who who will he be for you i mean
what
how do you envision with your new head
coach in a new system
coming in or at least a new head coach
with his system coming in
how do you envision a guy who's a buck
66 being used in the national football
league
yeah this guy can play all over the
field you know he can play inside
outside he can be
in the backfield uh i think that when
you talk about
his skill set as a route runner he's got
unique length and
really strong hands uh and the
the fun thing with our offense coaching
staff and coach siriani
uh is when he when we talk about these
guys there
he's he this house started he'll go all
right devonta smith
and this is how we're going to use them
and these are the routes we're going to
use them
and then when we're trying to kind of
get back to the top of the mountain we
talk about what kind of
characteristics we're looking for and
this guy the toughness that this guy
brings to the table that you you just
see it i mean we we drafted a
a kind of hybrid linebacker safety in
six rounds
uh jacoby stevens and and you watch
plays like i mean
he's trying to knock him out you know
and he pops right back up you know
it's like dumb be like so uh he's got
unique toughness
uh as well as your unique playing style
howie roseman gm of the philadelphia
eagles
um executive vice president here on the
rich eisen show
your quarterback situation um i i'll be
honest with you your new head coach
um saying that this is a that you can't
name one because he
you know everybody just got there and
it's joe flacco and it's jalen hurts is
is this not jalen hurts his gig here in
philly
now we're post-draft well when well
there's a lot to like about jalen hurts
there's no
doubt about it i mean you go back to the
reasons that we drafted him and the
skill set that he
provides and that he has and um
really as you talk about another guy who
exhibits exceptional toughness and
how many games he's won he won as a
college football player and
then you watched him every day you
watched him get better you watched him
really get better from alabama to
oklahoma and then
oklahoma through the pre-draft process
and then when we got him on the grass
you know seeing him and how he got
better but
when you talk about coach siriani and
for him everything is earned
you know we feel great about jalen but
he wants to have
uh competition everywhere and so
obviously we got some some
veterans who have so many skins on the
wall that you know maybe that that's not
realistic to say but
um
and that's how he's always been so i
think that was that was kind of part of
it and certainly you're also talking
about a week before the draft and not
wanting to give
answers to the test right i guess so um
so so hertz uh obviously knows devonte
smith and
we know that um
my gosh i mean i i could go on and on
with you for about an hour and i
appreciate you you taking the time here
as you're driving around
carson wentz when did you realize that
this wasn't working out anymore was it
during the season
was it during the season that's just
like okay this is
a wrap because of x y and z that i'd
love to know what you could fill in here
when did you realize that this had to
this had to you know end i mean
i mean there there's been no bigger fan
of carson went
to myself and and really he was
organization
and you see it with with what we did to
trade up to get them and then extend
them
um after we won the super bowl and there
was great communication with him and his
team
and and his agents who we have a great
relationship with
and during the season it was it was
again not not our most fun
season really rich um and so you know
you're trying to get through it and
uh get through the moment and not really
have those conversations and uh
amazingly enough really we still had a
chance towards the end of the season
um but as we went past it and went
through this coaching search and had
more conversations
with him as well and talked to him and
you know
we've probably realized that sometimes a
fresh start is best for everyone
and if it would work out for our team as
well as him
maybe that was the direction that we
were going well and then combined with
the pick you got from miami and the
trade that we discussed at the outset of
this conversation
and your own uh based on if wence works
out in
indianapolis with frank reich as a
reunion and everyone expects that to
to work out that way you could have
three first-round draft choices next
year and that leads to
a conversation amongst my colleagues
that you can utilize that to get whoever
you want at the quarterback position
next year
or maybe even trade for somebody else
who you can't talk about right now
because you don't want to get fined um
is is this a jalen hurts one year
um audition for the gig in philadelphia
i think when you look at it you go back
to
us being in the super bowl in 2017 and
then
trying to run it back in 2018 and man
there was a moment in that
new orleans game that i felt like we
were going back to the championship game
and
then the following year won the division
and we were doing some short-term things
to win and i feel like there are moments
with your football team where you do
whatever it takes and
certainly we're we're doing trying to do
whatever it takes to
win more than that just one super bowl
and
then we kind of got got an opportunity
here
to maybe get our cap back right and to
get a bunch of draft picks and
i think i saw um that we have the most
draft capital anything in the league so
at the end of the day we have the
flexibility at any position to improve
our football team going forward and
we're all proving ourselves at every
position every day you know including me
including everyone in our building and
getting that fire
and passion back to make sure that that
works out you know and obviously you
know it could work out with jalen where
he's just so supremely talented and he's
used to having the pressure and then the
crucible of philadelphia and then
obviously that informs your choices of
what you do with those
first-round selections i am mandated to
ask you this because i asked it of kyle
shanahan the other day when he was on
the show
when you heard that aaron rodgers was
upset
and that report came out on thursday did
you maybe make a call a yolo call before
the draft just in the same way that uh
kyle shanahan did to green bay
yeah i'll tell you what rich you know
what we're uh
we're not going to talk about anyone on
anyone else's team and any names but
you know you know this our fans know
this you know it's our job to look at
everything
and any opportunities out there to
improve
any avenue to make this team better
that's our job
okay i i you know i'm i'm mandated to
ask you these questions how you know i'm
just a curious guy sitting here and
you're just been
you've been in the middle of everything
i mean everything
it's it you know well what'd you say
it's the crucible
the crucible what do you call it the
crucible of philadelphia what is that
that's going to be
that's going to be the title of my book
one day
i'll give you a blurb if you want to
blurb how he'll give you a blurb i'm
very i like that yeah you know what our
blurb is our blurb is
walking around uh lincoln financial
field before the first ever home game
you and i
that's right i was just
[Laughter]
i wasn't on nfl network yet even that
was not even
i was not the gym either so we've come a
long way my man
we go way back thanks for the call howie
i greatly appreciate it let's and i
again i know you got oh i guess last one
did you play rock paper scissors with
nick siriani because i haven't found
anybody i asked a whole bunch of
prospects
did you do that did he really do that or
was he joking
not only did not not only did i did it
but i beat
but i beat his butt and i'm not gonna
play again i'm retired i'm the king of
rock
paper scissors it's a walk off so he was
was he being serious
and he he he was being serious because
he's got a lot of competitive things
going
but you know for me i beat him it was
two out of three i retired the champ i
dropped the mic
game over that's still all right very
good
best to your family howie thanks for the
time greatly appreciate it thank you
thank you that's how he roseman gm of
the eagles
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here